dude I've been getting up at like five
yeah it's the [ __ ] right I believe the
hype yeah I'm in it oh my God
it's just so peaceful yeah there's the
least amount of distractions that in
that time period because no one is up no
one is on email no one's you're not
getting any notifications no nobody's
doing anything yet so you can really
take those like two hours and and focus
on whatever the [ __ ] it is for me at
least that's like
I don't know it's just I might I might
damn near go to sleep at nine just to
watch a movie at five in the morning
yeah
foreign
Ted
you know well I probably wouldn't do
that but I mean I'm curious
if that would if you really could like
lock in yeah just put a put a movie on
yeah or like an episode or something
while you're eating breakfast yeah Chuck
Dune up on the fridge as you make coffee
yeah yeah
just throw on Twin Peaks on the old
washing machine
you know just just do your thing yeah no
I um yeah I was just mainly catching up
on jet lag and
cleaning up bought some crazy wardrobe
options so you know I've been trying to
put those out in the world okay
or a vest for the first time the other
day nice it was cool but you know that
feeling when you try something new oh
yeah on on the Wardrobe yeah because we
had we had developer style for a long
time yeah it's just just t-shirt hoodie
jacket jeans yeah you know whatever so
wearing a vest was crazy yeah because
half of your brain is like you look
[ __ ] stupid yeah and the other half
is like no feel confident yeah yeah no
no you could pull this off you gotta
feel you know you feel good right now
reassuring yeah I'm speaking of Dune
that's that's pretty much my wardrobe
now what dude yeah I'm like dressed like
a c character like a hot dog vendor in
Dune that's my wardrobe now
I got some crazy ass like Tech pants
okay you know I had I broke out this
pair that I've been saying
since I bought them this is so dumb I
paid like 300 bucks for him I'm like
I'll wear these now I'm gonna make these
work and I let them sit for a month now
it's outside the return policy so I just
have to
I gotta like try to own it what are Tech
pants like the technology pants no
that's like a little LCD yeah yeah yeah
screens in them yeah they gotta yeah
it's like with those belts one of those
belts that had the screen on them they
used to say [ __ ]
I think you can still get those at the
mall
this is that but it depends for him yeah
no it's got a Nintendo Wii charging
ports
it's got a it's got a pocket for your
Wii controller yeah so you just just put
the joy-con sticks in there
Tech pants got mini USB ports in case
you want to charge your [ __ ] LG
Chocolate
battery-powered fan
for what you're nuts yeah you just load
three double a batteries in there and
just cool off your balls yeah yeah
[ __ ] sick dude no like I only know I
only call them Tech pants because like
people use that word tech for like kind
of like windbreaker material I guess so
it's just some pants like that okay I I
knew I was dumb for buying them because
when you know when you buy some [ __ ] on
like a designer website and the dude
looking at you is just crazy looking
like he he had a oh like the model the
model yeah he had like such a unique
look yeah yeah and the clothes it was
like
I I like he looks like alien he looks
like from the future yeah yeah like this
is not me yeah you know yeah like this
guy is like six seven yeah just
[Laughter]
I don't look like that when I put these
on these are going to look bad yeah yeah
you know I saw me and him I guess yeah
and then yeah now I got these crazy ass
designer pants
that's funny
yeah man that those models dude yeah
even the guys that I saw when I went to
that Dior thing and I like saw them in
person yeah it was like yeah I was like
what the [ __ ] what do your parents look
like yeah how did you turn out like that
no they look carved out of something
yeah they're not like it's not like
they're we're not saying they're
ugly or even like super hot or it's just
like they're unique yeah no they just
have literally unique jaw bones yeah and
skull structure and it's like bright
green eyes yeah yeah yeah what race even
though yeah they'll be pale as hell
they're they're eye sockets are sunken
in hella deep yeah they have bright
piercing blue eyes yeah and their hair
is naturally translucent yeah
you know they have clear hair yeah
somehow wow yeah
like not bald they have clear braids
and then their their cheeks are
naturally just
yeah
and they're long they're wearing some
crazy Tech pants always wearing tack
pants yeah
and and even the way they mix and match
it you know they'll wear some
windbreaker material with dress shoes
yeah [ __ ] that should not go together no
shirt yeah yeah and all you say is damn
that's scarf yeah that [ __ ] is fire yeah
yeah it's cool as hell yeah
and you put it on your little body and
you're like
yeah your brain is like no you look good
go outside bro rock that [ __ ] be
confident yo I think I think I just saw
Mr tumnus walking down the street
looking dude from Narnia just like the
small little man with the hood feet
I gotta get a picture of this guy
Mr tumness I think that's what his name
is
seeing
just the yeah the hooved man with the
scarf these are Tech pants yeah yeah
got it
it's like do you have hooves no these
are dress shoes these are Dior
Oh I thought those were your toes
they're sick
they're cool and I look good
designer Mr dominance Mr Thomas dude
foreign
it's
[Music]
the style of the sweater nah dude tell
the truth that's your
that's your actual body
you're just born like that
yeah bro who played Mr tumness
no not you and McGregor no this is
[ __ ] uh this is Young Xavier from
X-Men yeah what man that's range right
there
that's some serious reasons he's a
famous actor doesn't it yeah it's a
James McCabe McAvoy um
what how else do you think you would
pronounce that
James McAvoy that's what it is yeah yeah
yeah you know what's great they've not
seen us for the last 20.
oh yeah
oh damn so we can't even put the Mr
tumness picture
we will put it on top of the title card
that's fine that's even funnier yeah it
is but remember you know it it the pain
the pain customers they got to see it
yeah right right oh yeah okay so if you
want to see the last
15 to 20 minutes of this episode
you know where you can find that or if
you don't it's tmgstudios.tv and then if
you sign up for the studios tear you'll
get all of our shows yeah which is just
this show now okay yeah we're canceling
the other one yeah everyone's taking it
back to basics